we have some major very consequential
news from the Supreme Court major
decisions that the Supreme Court don't
happen every day we got a very very
important decision yesterday where the
Supreme Court has decided that the
language of the Civil Rights Act of 1964
protects LGBT workers under the sex
discrimination provision now this is
something I've been talking to you about
for years and in fact since the June of
2015 Supreme Court decision which said
states can't ban same-sex marriage
we knew we predicted we've been watching
as the the sort of new focus of anti-gay
bigotry has been employment
discrimination so-called religious
freedom when it comes to LGBT workers
and even though LGBT workers even though
LGBT folks have been able to marry in
all 50 states since June of 2015 in many
states you can still legally fire
someone for their perceived or actual
sexual orientation and perceived as an
important part of that you don't
actually have to be LGBT to be fired if
someone thought you were as crazy as
that is and in many states either way it
is legal so this decision from the
Supreme Court was a six to three
decision which with Donald Trump's
appointee Neill Gorsuch writing the
majority opinion which we will address a
Gorsuch was joined by Chief Justice John
Roberts a bush appointee as well as Ruth
Bader Ginsburg a justices Breyer
Sotomayor and Kagan so all of this goes
back to title 7 of the Civil Rights Act
of 64 and that seventh title seven very
clearly says workers can't be
discriminated against by their employers
on the basis of race religion national
origin and sex and the what was really
at issue in this case is whether sex as
designated in 1964 includes sexual
orientation and gender identity
so understand
that the people fighting for LGBT
discrimination here were Trump
administration lawyers the Trump
administration was the the side arguing
that back in 1964 when people talked
about sex discrimination they met bias
against men or women quite simply that
they argued Trump's lawyers did that
this provision in 1964 does not include
sexual orientation it doesn't include
gender identity and that if you want to
protect those characteristics you would
need a new law that the sixty-four law
would not protect them now the
counter-argument which is a strong one
that ultimately was accepted by the
court and and the court sided with this
argument the other argument was any
decision made about sexual orientation
or transgender status is by definition
about sex as designated in 1964 so I'll
give you an example if you're
discriminating against someone because
they are a man attracted to other men
right which would be sexual orientation
discrimination you are singling them out
as men attracted to men rather than
women attracted to men meaning their
male sex is part of the discrimination
period another example if you are firing
someone because they are transgender it
is because you've evaluated that their
biological birth sex differs from their
current gender identity and thus sex is
part of that discrimination so this is a
very important decision
two of the three big pillars of anti-gay
discrimination have been toppled have
been locked knocked down in the last
five years
so back in 2015 Supreme Court decided
you can't stop people from being married
even if they are both men or both women
same-sex marriage bans are banned now in
2020 almost exactly five years later the
Supreme Court decided that employees
cannot be discriminated against on the
basis of their sexual orientation and
gender identity those are two of the
three pillars the last pillar would be
in
looting sexual orientation in business
non-discrimination law in the sense of
you can choose in many states to refuse
service to someone on the basis of their
sexual orientation real or perceived
there are many states that have outlawed
this but there are many states that have
not and a Supreme Court decision on that
would be sort of breaking down the third
anti-gay pillar now there are some
caveats here this is a good decision and
this is the right decision but there are
some important things to think about
first of all this decision from the
Supreme Court may well prevent some LGBT
folks from being fired but others are
still going to be fired and employers
will just be more careful about how they
do it they certainly won't say it has
anything to do with sexual orientation
or gender identity but it still could be
and there are going to be a lot of legal
cases very expensive legal cases that
will be fought over can you prove that
it was actually because of sexual
orientation or gender identity this is a
big problem in general in employment
discrimination number two many states
don't require an explanation about why
you're firing someone
these are at-will states where an
employer can just say your position has
has been eliminated we no longer require
your services and that would make it
very difficult to really know if one of
these protected statuses is at play now
there are also other legal
infrastructures like for example the
Fair Housing Act which aren't affected
by this decision
so the Fair Housing Act will maybe be
fought in court and you could point to
this decision as president but right now
the Fair Housing Act doesn't ban
discrimination against for example LGBT
tenants so a landlord could say I don't
want LGBT tenants in a lot of states and
that would not be banned by the Fair
Housing Act
maybe this decision from yesterday could
be used to justify changing the Fair
Housing Act now just one other really
important thing for context the Trump
administration just rolled back
protections for trans people two days
ago so yesterday's decision is progress
it's a step forward and on Monday we had
a step back and this is all still a
really big fight and this is
one piece of the pie one piece of the
puzzle lastly and very importantly if we
don't vote Donald Trump out in November
he gets to pick in all likelihood more
Supreme Court justices and he will
mostly choose people who will fall on
the wrong side of causes like these now
you a lot of people are gonna say but
David hold on Gorsuch who trump selected
was with the majority here that's right
he happened to get it right but let's be
frank this was a really obvious case the
three justices who dissented III DeMint
Lee disagree with and this was a
relatively easy case all things
considered if we want to be sure that we
get more decisions like this in the
future we have to be absolutely positive
that it's going to be Joe Biden
appointing Supreme Court justices rather
than Donald Trump let's not forget about
that as we are just four and a half
months from a presidential election
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would
like and it's completely free they do
have a paid version with different tiers
where you can create more virtual credit
card numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy comm slash Pakman